the very fact that people see this as
normal speak loudly as of the Taiwan's
tolerance and acceptance and diversity
public sector cannot just do everything
by itself it's not the era of planned
governance anymore
mostly the innovations come from the
private sector and the civil society and
spaceless like this are links between
the private sector the civil society and
the public sector
the idea of open governance this gained
foothold
I think only after the sunflower
movements occupy where people for the
first time demonstrated in the
Parliament that they are able to talk
about the trade service agreement this
really was the landmark change and
everything else that we see as that is
kind of repercussion of this kind of
demonstration including this post up
digital ministry in my childhood people
wouldn't even entertain the idea of a
woman running for president but for the
last election we've had two ladies
running for the president and and people
generally see it as final right so in in
the brief span of maybe just thirty
years that society has just evolved so
much
you